welcome back to pierce organizations now
decades as Wikileaks founded Julian
Assange moved into the Ecuadorian
Embassy to avoid extradition to United
States he's still fighting but now from
behind the bars of the toughest prison
in Britain belmarsh to some he's a free
speech martyr to others a threat to
National Security they might not speak
to his wife and former lawyer but first
a reminder of Julian assange's story
[Music]
my story behind the biggest leak in
intelligence history profile on me
editorial all right
the United States must pronounce it's
reached out against
[Applause]
today is an important Victory but it by
no means a races seven years of
detention without charge
[Music]
he does not deserve to be in a super max
prison he's an innocent person
[Music]
[Applause]
well Richard Tyson Porter are still with
me plus I'm joined by Junior nassandra's
wife and his former lawyer Stella and in
America former U.S national security
adviser John Bolton so welcome to all of
you welcome to you um incredibly
difficult
way to lead your life your husband is in
Belmont I've been to belmarsh it's an
incredibly high security president it's
a pretty Grim place to be locked up he's
been there nearly four years now having
also had seven years of no liberty in
the Ecuadorian Embassy
where is this going to go what do you
hope to achieve what do you think may
happen here
well Julian faces a potential sentence
in the United States of 175 years for
doing journalistic work for receiving
information from a source and Publishing
it and it was in the public interest it
was about U.S war crimes in Iraq and
Afghanistan and he revealed tens of
thousands of Civilian deaths that had
not been acknowledged before and war
crimes that have never been prosecuted
let me play Devil's Advocate as a
journalist I thought that a lot of the
stuff that appeared in the New York
Times and the guardian and various other
newspapers who acted in collusion with
Julian and Wikileaks over those
Revelations they redacted a lot of the
more sensitive stuff which might lead to
people's lives being impacted by the
revelations Wikileaks didn't they just
put it all out as a journalist you would
never do that so they weren't really
acting as journalists they were acting
as here it all is and work it out for
yourselves whereas the newspaper editors
acted like what I would say proper
journalists should do which is to be
careful about exactly what you put in
the public domain do you accept that I
don't accept it because it's not true
Wikileaks did actually redact all of
those Publications from the Manning that
Manning gave to WikiLeaks in fact it was
in cooperation with those newspapers
they told Wikileaks what had to be
redacted and then Wikileaks published it
redacted in fact Wikileaks withheld
fifteen thousand documents from the
Afghan war logs got criticized over
redacting too much in relation to Iraq
and in relation to Cable gate in fact it
was the guardian that published a
password which led to the cables being
published and in fact they were
published by a U.S publication first so
Wikileaks and in the extradition
hearings there has been witness
testimony about people who are working
with Wikileaks at the time that Julian
did in fact take every precaution to
redact any names that could be
um at risk okay Ambassador Bolton thank
you very much for joining me uh first of
all why is America so intent on bringing
Julian Assange to unbelievably Draconian
justice of 175 years I the rest of his
life in prison
well I think that's a small amount of
the sentence he actually deserves he's
committed clear criminal activity he's
no more a journalist than the chair I'm
sitting on the information that he
divulged did in fact put many people in
Jeopardy it undercut the ability of the
United States to have confidential
diplomatic Communications not just with
other foreign governments but in many
countries with dissidents people who
even speaking to American diplomats
could find themselves in trouble and so
you know he uh he's been complaining
about his treatment over the past period
of time he's the one who sought asylum
in the Ecuadorian Embassy now he faces
extradition to the United States I I
presume he will get due process in the
United Kingdom to determine whether
extradition should go forward and when
he gets to the United States he'll get
due process here and I hope he gets at
least 176 years in jail for what he did
Stella well of course Ambassador Bolton
is kind of the ideological Nemesis of
Julian he has during his time for the
Bush Administration later the Trump
Administration
sought to undermine the international
legal system ensure that the U.S is not
under the international Criminal Court's
Jurisdiction and if it was Mr Bolton
might uh in fact be prosecuted under the
ICC he was one of the chief cheerleaders
of the Iraq War which Julian then
exposed through these Lakes so he has a
conflict of interest here Ambassador
Bolton
well that's ridiculous I have an opinion
so does so does assange's wife I guess
we both get to speak them uh you know I
think that what she fears is being
brought to the United States and having
Assange put under trial if he's innocent
uh if you can she can at least show
reasonable doubt that he's not guilty
he'll go free what's she worried about I
guess what she's worried about is a fair
trial because it's pretty clear what the
attitude towards him is well let her say
a large number that's fine but
let let her say joy and Assange cannot
get a fair trial in America let her say
it okay well I cannot get a fair trial
in America because he is being
prosecuted under the Espionage Act and
he cannot bring a public interest
defense he cannot say I published this
information because it was in the public
interest
um precisely because it is under the
Espionage Act and it is the first time
that a publisher has ever been published
uh prosecuted under this act something
that constitutional lawyers in the
United States have been warning uh could
happen for the past 50 years and the New
York Times And The Washington Post say
this this prosecution strikes at the
heart of the First Amendment Ambassador
Bob well I think I think they are badly
wrong on that he's in effect a hacker
and a person who breaks and enters into
uh secure information not even the U.S
election prosecuted under the let me
finish now the fact he's prosecuted
under the Espionage Act uh is something
that's been part of American law for
many many years plenty of other people
have been prosecuted under it uh and and
that goes directly to the issue of
whether a country can protect uh
classified information that there's
absolutely no doubt about and I would
say to the esteemed editors of the
Washington Post in the New York Times
when you try and equate yourself with
Julian Assange you're making a very
dangerous gesture because while you're
saying the first amendment should apply
to him a different kind of legal system
could move it in the opposite direction
and put you under prosecution as well
it's a very dangerous position to take
and an inaccurate one they're doing two
completely different things okay one set
of them are publishing news the other
the other is damaging American National
Security Richard sauce you've been
jumping a bit again in here quickly yeah
first of all it's ridiculous that he's
in belmarsh prison For Heaven's Sake I
mean I just cannot understand that as
you've said you know it's it's the most
uh the most high security so that's
absurd but if this can't be resolved and
it sounds to me actually as though it
may not is there not a sort of
international jurisdiction because there
was there was actually International uh
important issues here that do need
resolving and both sides have a very
strong robust argument and I wonder
whether it's almost like a test case
internationally it's really really
significant really important and it
needs to be heard I think in order to
get some Stella Before I Let You Go how
is he physically because he's been in
ill health he was isolated during covid
for many months couldn't see anybody
including you how is he while he's
suffering profoundly and his health is
declining by the day you know he's a
caged animal and you can just imagine
what that does to a person he's far away
from from me and the kids he only sees
us uh once or twice a week
um and he has there's no reason for him
to be in a high security prison and
actually on Saturday we're doing a human
chain around the British Parliament to
call for his release
Stella it's good to see thank you for
coming in uh it's a it's a fascinating
debate it got us to the heart of where
Free Speech begins and ends and it's
complex it's difficult I mean there's no
doubt about that but I appreciate you
coming in can I can
um Wikileaks released the names of the
membership of the British national party
in 2008. this is not just about what's
happening to Julian Sergeant America
it's about all of us I wanted to thank
you for that thank you uh really
appreciate you coming thank you to
Ambassador Bolton I appreciate you
coming uh from America too thank you
very much indeed